Traduttore: Eloisa Zendali
Revisore: Giorgio Fighera
Mi ci vuole un respiro,
per parlare di corto circuiti emozionali.
Potrei chiedervi
di venire qui e guardarvi,
e il corto circuito partirebbe.
Mi occupo di bimbi che non ce la fanno
e di bimbi che fanno fatica a scuola,
di bimbi che fanno fatica a crescere,
di bimbi che non si sentono capiti,
di bimbi che soffrono.
E questo ha modificato
la mia storia di scienziato.
Quindi l'altro giorno ero
in un polo apprendimento,
che è dove aiuto questi bimbi,
e in questo polo apprendimento
una di queste bimbe mi guardava
perché io ero preoccupata
su come iniziare oggi
a parlarvi in pochissimi minuti
di cosa facciamo noi,
e del perché sono qui.
E l'ho guardata e le ho detto:
“Sai, non so da dove cominciare”.
Lei mi ha sorriso e mi ha detto:
“Dall'inizio devi cominciare,
si inizia sempre dall'inizio".
E quindi, ecco, lì vedete me
che in qualche modo
rappresenta il mio inizio,
il mio inizio di scienziato
e la mia partenza per andare
a studiare, a capire - che cosa?
Quello che da un certo punto di vista
mi ha affascinato per tantissimo tempo,
cioè il rapporto
tra il cervello e la mente,
tra il cervello e l'anima.
Tra cosa sentiamo,
e com'è possibile che sentiamo così.
E quindi ho passato anni ed anni
ad affascinarmi per questa
struttura straordinaria:
il cervello è una struttura straordinaria.
In millesimi di secondo,
in questo momento,
voi avete milioni
di miliardi di connessioni
che mettono in moto
tutta una trasformazione
di ciò che siete stati
e di ciò che sarete.
E a modificare tutto questo
sono le informazioni che stanno entrando
e che, in qualche modo,
seminano qualche cosa di nuovo
che determina potatura
in ciò che voi siete stati fino ad adesso
e nuove gemmazioni.
Questo miracolo
che misura un meccanismo che si chiama
"Zona di Sviluppo Prossimale"
è uno dei processi
più affascinanti della vita:
è quello che rappresenta l'essere vivente
che ciascuno di noi,
momento dopo momento,
sceglie di essere.
Quindi, dopo avere studiato tanto
tutti questi meccanismi,
sono tornata in Italia.
E che cosa mi è successo?
Ho incontrato un bimbo,
l'ho incontrato in un
corridoio verde, di ospedale,
le mura erano veramente terribili,
davano l'idea di qualche cosa
che non curava ma opprimeva.
Questo bimbo aveva
otto adulti insieme a lui,
oltre i genitori, gli assistenti vari,
i docenti vari, gli ospedalieri.
E l'infermiera gli ha detto
che lì comandavo io.
Quello che io ho fatto
è stato un gesto da lontano,
in fondo al corridoio:
cioè mi sono abbassata
e gli ho sorriso.
Questo gesto ha fatto sì che lui
sia corso verso di me,
mi abbia preso per il camice
e mi abbia detto quella parola
che leggete: "iutimi".
Ora, io di questo bimbo non so più niente,
ma quello che so
è che ha cambiato la traiettoria
della mia storia da scienziato,
perché ho pensato
che se tutto quello che sapevamo
non aiutava un bambino,
e se una comunità intera che si muoveva
al punto di dargli otto adulti,
non lo stava aiutando,
perché lui chiedeva aiuto
a un estraneo in camice
in un corridoio verde d'ospedale,
qualcosa in tutto questo
nostro sistema non aiutava.
E quindi mi sono rimessa a studiare
e mi sono rimessa a studiare
quello che in termini, così,
di scienze e di deep science,
si chiama "neuroplasticità"
e in termini educativi si chiama
"Potenziamento della Zona
di Sviluppo Possibile".
Cioè ho cominciato a studiare
come si potessero esercitare
i domini cerebrali
nel determinare
miglioramenti nel linguaggio,
nella capacità di concentrazione,
di memoria, di attenzione,
di intelligenza numerica.
Sono diventata brava.
Brava al punto che i bimbi cambiavano,
e dal punto di vista delle ricerche
avevo grandissimo successo,
perché a livello di ricerca sperimentale
quello che ottenevamo
era quello che si chiama proprio
"Potenziale migliore della struttura
neuropsicologica individuale".
Se posso darvi un esempio è:
il cervello gemma,
in millesimi di secondo,
le memorie che noi imprimiamo
attraverso le informazioni che riceviamo.
Quindi, se vogliamo capire
che cosa fa, per esempio,
la vita a scuola in un bambino,
basta che facciamo un calcolo,
un calcolo che io diedi
al Ministero tanti anni fa, e cioè:
facciamo millesimi di secondo
per centesimi di secondo
per decimi di secondo
per secondi, per minuti, per ore,
per giorni, per mesi, per anni
che un bimbo sta a scuola:
ottenete un numero che tende all’infinito.
Quel numero misura
quello che ciascuno
degli adulti che incontrerà
determina nel suo connettoma:
la trasformazione del suo sé.
È un potere immenso.
E quindi mio figlio, in un tema
in seconda elementare,
ha scritto che sua mamma,
quando ha finito di imparare
di fare lo scienziato,
si è messa a fare
la maestra delle maestre
perché io ho cominciato
a spiegare agli insegnanti
che cosa si determinava
nella neuroplasticità
e nel potenziale umano.
Ed ero convinta di avercela fatta.
Ma non è stata così. Perché?
Perché qualche tempo dopo,
e in questo ci avviciniamo all’oggi
di cui vi voglio parlare,
incontro un altro bimbo,
un bimbo da cui avevamo
ottenuto un cambiamento,
in termini di profilo
cognitivo, straordinario,
perché aveva recuperato
una deviazione standard e mezzo
da quello che si chiama genericamente
quoziente di intelligenza generale.
E questo bimbo ad un certo punto mi dice:
“Ma adesso che mi hai tolto gli errori,
mi togli che mi fanno male?"
E io non ero preparata
a capire il rapporto
tra l'errore della mente
e il dolore nella mente.
E soprattutto non avevo riflettuto
su che cosa fosse
il meccanismo del dolore.
Ma se adesso io chiedessi a voi,
mille persone adulte,
di ricordarvi della vostra vita
e dei vostri errori -
e non intendo gli errori a scuola
del leggere, scrivere e far di conto,
ma gli errori della vita,
e vi chiedessi se hanno una traccia
più importante nella vostra storia
gli errori che avete fatto
o il dolore che vi ha provocato,
e che cos'è che determina
la reazione in voi,
penso che la risposta sarebbe unanime:
è il dolore che determina la risposta.
Ma cosa fa il dolore?
Per spiegarvelo in pochissimi minuti,
altrimenti mi sgridano,
vi chiedo dei gradi di libertà,
cioè vi chiedo di fare
quello che, in qualche modo,
ci aiuta a capire subito.
Datevi una pizzicata, ma forte,
ma proprio una pizzicata.
E vi chiedo: questo che cos’è,
dolore o sofferenza?
È dolore.
Perché abbiamo milioni di alert
che dalla struttura
che noi andiamo a colpire
ci mandano delle
informazioni neuroelettriche.
Perché dal cervello attraverso
il sistema nervoso periferico
questo ribollitore biochimico
che produce energia
manda informazioni
e dice: “Alert! Ti duole”.
Perché ci dice “ti duole"?
Perché ci dobbiamo ricordare
che non dobbiamo più ricorrere
a quel determinato tipo di situazione,
perché ci fa male.
Quindi va a tracciare
le memorie, perché dice:
scappa da di là, che ti duole.
Allora cosa sono
queste emozioni straordinarie?
Ecco voi potete leggere:
sono processi incredibili
a livello neurofunzionale.
Ai miei studenti lo spiego
questo ribollitore biochimico
che produce energia
perché noi dormiamo
e produciamo tre Hertz,
siamo svegli come in questo momento
e ne produciamo nove.
Ma basta un’emozione,
una goccia qualunque di emozione
come quella che adesso provo io
e che fa sì che sebbene io spieghi
queste cose a contesti molto più complessi
io sia molto più emozionata adesso,
perché ho uno scopo grande,
quello di parlare con voi.
E alla fine ve lo dirò.
E questa emozione è talmente potente
che sebbene il mio cervello
sia molto addestrato,
la mia voce la manifesta.
E io non riesco a controllare la voce
perché l'emozione
è più potente del sistema cognitivo,
è il grande decisore.
Ed è un decisore intelligente
che però ha solo due risposte,
e la risposte sono:
“mi duole” o “mi fa bene”
“mi duole" o "mi fa bene".
Le emozioni nascono,
nel nostro sistema evolutivo,
per dirci: “scappa" se ci duole,
“tieni e cerca" se ci fa bene.
E come ce lo dice?
Ce lo dice attraverso un meccanismo,
straordinario, di tipo hertziale.
Se noi abbiamo un momento di gioia,
abbiamo un picco hertziale
in cui l'onda che si manifesta
è un'onda ad altissima intensità,
ma breve breve breve.
E perché un'onda ad altissima intensità
è breve breve breve?
Perché deve tracciarla,
la memoria di gioia;
ma siccome la gioia fa bene,
come ogni meccanismo che fa bene
il cervello lo deve cercare ancora
E quindi c'è l’ha breve,
il momento di gioia,
perché così si innescherà
il meccanismo della ricerca della gioia.
Ma se invece della gioia
noi proviamo angoscia, ansia, paura,
allora l’onda è molto diversa.
Perché è a bassa intensità,
sta sotto soglia coscienza,
non si fa vedere
dalla mente, sta lì sotto.
Perché deve dare un alert che dice:
Ricorda, ricorda, ricorda, ricorda.
Scappa da di qua, che ti duole.
Ed ecco che i nostri circuiti
vengono percorsi da onde
che dicono: scappa, perché ti duole.
E l'energia che produciamo
è un'energia che ci dice:
"Scappa che c'è dolore".
Sembra che non ci sia via d'uscita.
E invece c’è, eccome.
Vi ho detto che non è la mente
che controlla le emozioni.
Questa è una grandissima illusione.
Da scienziato cognitivo,
ad un certo punto ho dovuto arrendermi.
Provocatevi il conforto,
per esempio, come emozione.
Ci riuscite?
Provocatevi l’intesa.
Adesso ordinatevi di provare intesa
l'uno verso l’altro.
Non ci si riesce!
Ma guardate che abbiamo
degli interruttori,
e questi interruttori sono catalizzatori.
Non possiamo accendere la luce,
qui dentro, con la forza del pensiero:
dobbiamo andare all'interruttore giusto!
E l'interruttore giusto per le emozioni
lo dobbiamo capire qual è.
Per esempio, se vi chiedo,
per piacere, guardatevi negli occhi
l'un l'altro con intesa, vai.
Per piacere, abbracciatevi
30 secondi, dai, coraggio!
Per piacere, fatevi una carezza,
una carezza di conforto.
Se adesso noi misurassimo
il battito cardiaco,
misurassimo la temperatura,
guardassimo indicatori
come il colore della pelle,
e l’acidità del sudore
che è stato emanato,
noi avremo tutto un cambio di indici
perché noi abbiamo attivato
circuiti neuroelettrici potentissimi.
Questi sono gli organizzatori,
questi sono gli interruttori.
Pensate che trenta secondi di abbraccio
comandano all'amigdala
di produrre l’ossitocina,
l'ormone che determina,
nel momento del parto,
la possibilità di una donna
di resistere al dolore!
Trenta secondi di abbraccio.
Quindi, come dice mio figlio,
io adesso mi sono messa ad andare in giro
a spiegare alla gente
che l’imparare a guardare
i bambini negli occhi,
l’imparare ad abbracciarli,
l’imparare ad accarezzarli,
implica mettere nel circuito
delle memorie permanenti
che sono di emozioni
che costruiscono ben-essere
e non mal-essere.
È acqua e pane.
La scienza è ritornata all'acqua e pane.
E in quali memorie vanno le emozioni?
Le emozioni, è interessante,
perché mentre noi impieghiamo
tantissima fatica, per esempio,
per studiare, per ricordare,
noi lì andiamo in consumo di energia.
Le memorie che invece vengono determinate
da una traccia immediata
sono le memorie che tengono emozioni.
Ma se allora noi,
ad un certo punto del nostro
cortocircuito emozionale,
facciamo qualcosa come
quello che accade sempre,
cioè mentre per esempio io studio, imparo,
faccio fatica, sperimento ansia,
la mia memoria mette
in memoria ciò che studio
ma anche l'ansia
con cui ce l'ho messo.
E quando ritorno a prendere
dal cassettino della mia memoria
ciò che ho studiato,
riprendo non soltanto
le informazioni che ci ho messo,
ma anche le emozioni
con cui l’ho tracciato.
E quindi l'ansia entra nel circuito
e diventa un'informazione
che mi manda in corto.
E se io apprendo con paura,
io recupererò la paura;
e se io apprendo con senso di disistima,
io riprenderò la disistima.
Ma se io apprendo con sfida a me stesso,
io riprenderò la sfida a me stesso.
E questo, vi ho detto prima,
avviene per millesimi di secondo
fino ad anni di tempo
in cui il sistema educante
può determinare inquinamento
nei circuiti mentali
o pandemia di guarigione.
E io sono per questa
pandemia di guarigione,
anche perché da persona di scienza
quello che devo leggere
sono anche le scienze a fianco.
E le ricerche sull'epigenetica
mi hanno fatto tremare.
Perché? Perché studiando
cosa accade ai topolini
che durante la gravidanza
vengono messi nell'acqua ghiacciata,
e poi vengono fatti partorire,
ci si è accorti, e sono dei dati
che ci devono far pensare,
che non accade solo ai topi,
che i loro cuccioli
restano con l'alert della paura
per tre generazioni almeno.
Cioè è come se le memorie del dolore
non fossero soltanto individuali,
ma transgenerazionali.
Questo significa che noi tramandiamo,
per proteggere i nostri figli,
ciò da cui si devono proteggere.
Quali sono le due emozioni
più preoccupanti,
e che preoccupano più me?
Il senso di colpa e la paura.
Di queste non vi posso parlare,
ma vi posso dire quali sono
le emozioni antagoniste.
Al senso di colpa,
il grande antagonista
è il diritto all’errore.
Se noi ci mettiamo
in questa consapevolezza
che dobbiamo far crescere i nostri figli
nel diritto all’errore,
nell'errore come un processo di modifica
e di miglioramento continuo,
cambia il livello di consapevolezza.
Abbiamo detto sussurri e voci.
Beh, se noi diciamo
“bravo";"Bravo."; "Bravo!”
noi diamo informazioni
completamente differenti
perché è l'emozione
che facciamo transitare
attraverso l'indicatore
che stiamo utilizzando
che va a quel grande decisore e gli dice:
"Proteggiti", o "Non proteggerti".
Adesso vi racconto dell'ultimo bambino
perché ho diciotto secondi.
Questo ultimo bambino vi dice
perché sono venuta qui,
facendo una follia,
tra un congresso e l’altro,
perché sono in partenza per Parigi
per un congresso sul cervello
che mi mette molta più ansia ancora.
Quindi non è una buona giornata.
Ma allora, perché sono venuta qui?
Ve lo dico con la storia di Anselmo.
Anselmo è un bimbo Asperger
ad altissimo funzionamento cognitivo.
Come “Rain Man”, per darvi un’idea.
L’ho incontrato qualche anno fa
perché i genitori, due medici,
mi hanno detto:
"Tu aiuti tanti bimbi
nelle loro difficoltà.
Aiuta anche lui che parla quattro lingue,
risolve problemi di matematica
come se fosse al secondo
anno di università,
disegna il Duomo di Milano
in pochi secondi senza errori,
ma basta guardarlo e si agita
e va in tutti quei comportamenti tipici,
prototipici delle sindromi
autistiche importanti.
E quindi io non avevo mai provato
ad aiutare un bimbo
in quella che è la zona
di sviluppo prossimale delle emozioni.
Ma ho pensato che in questo
cervello straordinario,
se le due strutture sono strutture
che sincronicamente collaborano,
io potevo aiutare le emozioni
con la cognizione.
E cosa ho fatto?
Gli ho chiesto di segnare in un quaderno
tutte le cose che lui riteneva
fargli paura, angoscia,
metterlo in vulnerabilità.
E a ognuna di queste,
collegare la strategia
con cui vincerla, questa vulnerabilità.
Questa strategia non aveva importanza
che fosse particolarmente sofisticata.
Il più delle volte
era una strategia del tutto sua,
come battere i piedi a terra,
battere e schioccare le dita;
ma questo faceva sì
che questo flusso di corrente
dell'ansia se ne andasse.
Quindi lui ha compilato
quaderni e quaderni
di queste sue soluzioni,
ed è venuto a presentarlo
a un congresso di 100 insegnanti.
Avevamo addestrato, sentite la parola, lui
a non avere momenti di reazione
non favorevole a tanta gente
e tutte le insegnanti a non comportarsi
in maniera di agitarlo.
Ma ad un certo punto, mentre lui parlava,
una delle insegnanti si emoziona,
si mette a piangere,
si alza e applaude.
Quindi tutte le insegnanti,
100 insegnanti si mettono a piangere,
si alzano e applaudono, si commuovono.
Quindi lui va in panico
e mi scappa dietro una tenda.
Lo vado a prendere, battiamo per terra,
lo prendo per il mignolo,
ci troviamo ad una cioccolata -
e devo finire veloce veloce,
e alla cioccolata lui mi dice:
"Lucangeli, l'hai visto
il moltiplicatore?”
Io dico: "No, veramente.
Cosa vuoi dire?”
“C'erano 100 insegnanti, Lucangeli,
alcuni giovani, alcuni non tanto.
Quindi in media resteranno
altri 25 anni a scuola.
Ognuno di loro avrà
25 alunni almeno, in classe.
Quindi con questa ora di lezione,
io ho aiutato, nella mia vita,
62500 bambini."
E io sono qui per questo.
(Applausi)
Sono qui, e voglio dirlo,
perché voi mi aiutiate
a fare della scienza servizievole.
Sono qui, e voglio dirlo
perché voi mi aiutate -
e ci aiutiate, perché siamo in tanti,
a fare della scienza servizievole,
e a fare in modo che si diventi molti,
molti, molti di più di 62.500 persone.
Grazie, buona vita.
(Applausi)